this program is brought to you by Emory
University
if you intend to live you will fight and
that's my goal I don't have a grandbaby
it my oldest is 27 now I don't have a
grandbaby I must stay around for a while
so I'm try and do everything that I can
to stay up stay perky stay happy like me
like the world like everybody in it I'm
just gonna get up and do it there are
things that you can do it you can love
yourself no matter how broken out your
face might be or how broke down you may
feel that day is always something about
cheese that you can like every day and I
look for every day even if it's nothing
but putting on some eye shadow to make
me feel like oh my like the way I look
today so i will do those type things and
um I just believe that I have to make
every day the best day that it can be
for me
you
the preceding program is
by Emory University